called anything lame recently well the
woke police are on their way to get you
the problematic word was put on the
radar by the university of washington
lame ableism implied
this word is offensive even when it's
used in slang for uncool because it's
using a disability in a negative way
minority
offensive in various contexts
implies a less than attitude towards the
community being discussed mantra
cultural appropriation
many people in the buddhist and hindu
community hold this term as highly
spiritual and religious experience and
it is not to be used with nonchalance
webmaster
racist
the words may have been chosen to
emphasize the concept of a free master
that did no work and a slave that
followed the masters orders
an everyday word or an offensive slur
it takes an expert to tell the
difference nowadays